[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich euch frage ob er gerne verreist
bin ich mir sicher dass viele von euch
ja sagen werden aber glaubt mir liebe
visuelle politik zuschauer einige orte
dieser welt schaut man sich besser nur
auf postkarten oder über google street
view an ich spreche hier von orten an
dem du ohne weiteres um dein geld dann
handy oder sogar um dein leben gebracht
werden könnte ist sicher gibt es unter
euch aber auch einige die dieses risiko
und etwas nervenkitzel nicht scheuen und
sich unbekannte wenn auch gefährlicher
ort interessieren und sich vielleicht
sogar irgendwann mal besuchen wollen
deshalb haben wir hier auch visuell
politik für euch eine rangliste
gefährlichsten städte der welt
aufgestellt dabei haben sie allerdings
kriegsschauplätze ausgelassen wir denken
dass diese städte auf einer solchen
liste nichts zu suchen haben wir wollen
hier nicht über kriegsverbrechen
sprechen wer sich für dieses thema
interessiert der findet dazu eine ganze
reihe anderer interessanter videos auf
unseren kanal dieser rangliste haben wer
nach weltregionen gruppiert und zu ihrer
erstellung faktoren wie die anzahl an
tötungsdelikten oder raubüberfällen
herangezogen darüber hinaus haben wir
das ausmaß an korruption sowie
kriminelle machenschaften geht die
derart aber auch sozio ökonomischen
umstände berücksichtigt zudem sind die
zukunftsaussichten der jeweiligen region
in unsere bewertung mit eingeflossen und
wisst ihr was besonders bemerkenswert an
dieser liste ist nun die in ihr
aufgeführten städte haben sehr viele
gemeinsamkeiten diese sind armut
mangelnde chancengleichheit drogen und
denen die perspektiven für junge
menschen miteinander vermischt ergeben
diese probleme einen explosiven cocktail
ist der erst mal entzündet entsteht an
den unterschiedlichsten orten rund um
den erdball ein sich selbst
verstärkender kreislaufs kriminalität
und gewalt
und in diesem video stellen wir euch die
traurigen extremfälle dieses tags vor
keiner der von uns aufgelisteten orte
liegt dabei in europa dies liegt nicht
daran dass es bei uns etwa an unsichere
städten mangeln würde sicher könnte man
auch über marseille neapel mangel oder
die albanische gemeinte troja sprechen
aber die städte auf unserer liste
spielen in sachen gefährlichkeit in
einer ganz anderen liga die frage ist
also welche sind die gefährlichsten
städte der welt an welchen ordnung müsst
ihr sehr vorsichtig sein auch wenn ihr
euch noch mal schnell ein kühles getränk
kaufen wollt nun schnallt euch lieber
gut anwenden unsere heutige reise wird
wahrlich nichts für zart besaitete
gemüter wir werden orte der willkür und
gewalt kennenlernen unbeschreibliches
elend korruption und hoffnungslosigkeit
riesige städte die von zombies in real
life oder gar von brutalen vergewaltiger
beherrscht werden zustände welche selbst
den magen der übelsten barbaren ans
tageslicht befördern würden denn
manchmal da die in diesem video wirklich
denken die evolution des menschen seien
mehrere millionen jahre zurückgedreht
worden und immer wenn ihr denken werde
der gipfel des schreckens sei schon
erreicht werden wir euch etwas noch
schlimmeres zeigen aber eines nach dem
anderen
vom indischen ozean bis zur südsee
[Musik]
auf platz drei in asien ozeanien kommt
ran gut dran hohen liegt in myanmar dass
wir bis vor kurzem noch als wäre
markanten dieses land gleicht einem
pulverfass auch wenn rand und seit 2005
nicht mehr die hauptstadt mehr anders
ist ist immer noch die größte und
bedeutendste stadt des landes februar
2021 kam das preis eine 60er jahren sehr
mächtige militär wieder durch einen
putsch zur vollständigen macht im lande
jede aufkeimende protest wurde es von
den sicherheitskräften niedergeschlagen
durch die gewaltsame machtübernahme ist
verlor die landeswährung der knapp ein
drittel seines wertes dies versetzte den
ohnehin schwächelnden wirtschaft einen
weiteren schweren schlag zu schossen
armut und mit ihr die kriminalität in
die höhe der zeit warnt das deutsche
auswärtige amt auf seiner internetseite
vor reisen nach myanmar mit folgenden
worten
einsätze der sicherheitskräfte und
straßensperren sind an der tagesordnung
es kommt landesweite regelmäßig zu
sprengstoffanschlägen und gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen auch mit
schusswaffengebrauch ziele sind
militärische und staatliche
einrichtungen aber auch öffentliche
einrichtungen wie einkaufszentren oder
banken eine weitere verschärfung der
sicherheitslage kann nicht
ausgeschlossen werden in teilen von
rangun und mandalay hat das militär das
kriegsrecht verhängt ist bestehen
nächtliche ausgangssperren in einem
guten und anderen städten und regionen
und versammlungsverbote deutschen
staatsangehörigen wird empfohlen das
land zu verlassen wenn ihr also nicht
gerade opfer eines raubüberfalls oder
des anschlags solch einem verhalten
einwohner angemeldet besteht immer noch
die gefahr dass ein verirrtes
gummigeschoss euren weg kreuzt während
ihr euch die sehenswürdigkeiten der
stadt ansieht und dann könnt ihr euer
abenteuer nicht einmal mit euren
freunden teilen in das militärregime
blockiert soziale medien wird es einen
griff immer feste um das land legt
mehr us pläne zur einschränkung der
internetfirmen mit bbn verbot wie die
ems zu verbieten könnte natürlich nicht
entgegengesetzt zu den werken von visual
politik stehen denn wie schon george
orwell sagte wenn freiheit überhaupt
etwas bedeutet dann vor allem das recht
anderen leuten zu sagen was sie nicht
hören wollen und an dieser stelle fragt
ihr euch vielleicht auch daran gut nur
aus dem grund aufgenommen haben um
unserem sponsor strafschlag einen guten
aufhänger zu bieten aber nein ihr müsst
keine angst haben dass irgendein sponsor
auch nur ein jota an unseren inhalten
beeinflussen könnte denn ein solche
gründe sofort vom platz jagen und
ehrlich gesagt haben wir das auch schon
mal getan andererseits wenn der sowieso
schon dabei sind zu erklären deswegen
wie die ems nicht ganz unwichtig sind
für unsere freie gesellschaft und wir
uns selbst mit informations und
kommunikations realisieren warum sollten
wir uns diese botschaft nicht auch ein
wenig entlohnen lassen also aus georgia
gpm ist ein wirklich sicheres vpn
welches zum beispiel keinerlei
verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein durchschnitt privat wird wirken
nicht vor allen gefahren schützen die
ihnen es lauern man muss nach wie vor
umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber er stellt hierfür ein werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in kombination mit
anderen vorkehrungen eure aktionen
messen nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit
hilfe verschiedener sicherheitschefs
könnt ihr so ihre anonymität indes
erhöhen zb mit dem integrierten klien
wird dass alle cookies popups und so
weiter blockt weiterer fordert alles
diktieren ist dass ihr so tun können als
wären alle anderen ort so könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch website und internet
zugreifen in dem land in legale seiten
verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im urlaub
damit schlag der zensur und jim block
ein schnippchen netflix und andere
streaming dienste die ihre inhalte nur
in den usa anbieten von europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches internet fernsehen im
ausland drucken mit surf kein problem
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles denn
mit noch einem soft akonto könnt ihr
wirklich alle eure endgeräte im ibm
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
euren smart tv und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
von surf auch noch einen rabatt in höhe
von 83 prozent und obendrein den ersten
drei monate gratis dazu den link zu
diesem angebot findet ihr in dem unter
diesem video also nichts wie los
besonders surfer und damit glaser uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich ebenfalls
in die beschreibung gepackt haben wir
sind euch für jede unterstützung dankbar
denn damit hätte uns auch in zukunft
noch mehr und noch besser videos zu
liefern gut kommen wir nun zu unserem
nächsten kandidaten für die
gefährlichste stadt der welt
[Musik]
platz zwei geht an karachi
karachi liegt an der mündung des indus
am arabischen meer und besteht aus
diversen ineinander verwobenen gemeinden
in der kernstadt leben fast 15 millionen
menschen zusammen mit dem näheren umland
sind es sogar etwas 17 millionen damit
ist karachi nicht nur die
bevölkerungsreichste stadt pakistans
ziel zu den größten bevölkerungszentren
der welt natürlich ist sie auch ein
wirtschaftszentrum und ein solches die
naturgemäß die unterschiedlichsten
menschen an da überrascht es nicht dass
ethnischen und konfessionellen
spannungen auf den straßen spürbar sind
karachi liegt in der provinz sind aber
viele seiner einwohner sind keine cindy
sanou hds muslime aus indien zu ihnen
gesellen sich verstohlen aus den
gebieten entlang der grenze zu
afghanistan
leider ist ein beachtlicher teil dieser
vielschichtigen bevölkerung zu den
islamistischen fundamentalisten zu
zählen der hauptpfeiler menschen in
karachi ist aber die arme diese zwingt
viele in die kriminalität daher kommt es
beispielsweise häufig zu raubüberfällen
bei denen sich kriminelle banden die
endlosen verkehrsstaus zu nutze machen
nicht selten verursachen sie diese sogar
selbst mit hilfe von barrikaden es gibt
aber auch gute nachrichten denn die
örtlichen behörden versuchen dieses die
auch andere probleme zu lösen
[Musik]
euro ist das circa 150 millionen euro
schwere karachi safe city project ins
leben gerufen welches die installation
von 10.000 überwachungs kamera mit
gesichtserkennung in der stadt vorsieht
darüber hinaus sollen sämtliche
fahrzeugkennzeichen mit transpondern
ausgestattet welche dann ebenfalls von
diesem sicherheitssystem erfasst werden
können auf grund von zahllosen
korruptionsskandalen hängt dieses
ambitionierte projekt seinerzeit waren
allerdings gewaltig hinterher
[Musik]
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt hat man bereits
sieben geschlagene jahre verloren aber
er ahnt es sich ja schon das ist noch
nicht alles leider drohen euch in
karachi noch viele weitere gefahren und
nehmen wir nur einmal die
luftverschmutzung aufgrund des massiven
straßenverkehrs unter unschönen sitze
seien müll einfach unkontrolliert zu
verbrennen gilt karachi ist mit der am
stärksten verschmutzten städte der welt
des weiteren ist die wasserversorgung
und abwasserentsorgung einfach grauen
kraft die wasserknappheit hat sogar
schon dazu geführt dass die mafia sich
das geschäft mit dem begehrten las unter
den nagel gerissen hat die
wasserleitungen der stadt an und
verkauft das so gestohlene wasser dann
an die einwohner zurück bei denen es
gerade wegen er nicht mehr ankommt neben
dem handel mit land und drogen ist dies
eines der einträglichsten geschäft des
organisierten verbrechens in karachi im
gegensatz zu sauberen wasser oder
sanitären und medizinischen
einrichtungen sind moskitos in karachi
allerdings eher weniger knapp und da
diese nicht selten gefährliche
krankheiten übertragen ist die
kombination all dieser faktoren überaus
naja unglücklich wenn ihr euch also
nicht gerade zusammen mit der mafia an
der lukrativen wasser hehlerei
beteiligen wollt solltet ihr karachi
vielleicht eher meiden
auf platz eins kommt port moresby die
hauptstadt faktoren originals ist
aufgrund von armut ein derart
gefährlicher ort dass der inselstaat für
das apec treffen mehr 2018 zu
ungewöhnlichen maßnahmen greifen musste
das jährliche treffen der organisation
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit den
pazifik raum wurde in jedem jahr in port
moresby ausgerichtet um die sicherheit
der hochrangigen gäste mit frisch imping
just den tod oder myspace zu
gewährleisten wurden gleich drei
kreuzfahrtschiffe angemietet auf denen
sämtliche delegation während der
konferenz beherbergt wurden denn eine
übernachtung in der stadt wurde als zu
gefährlich eingestuft aber die armut
kommt nicht von irgendwo her die
arbeitslosigkeit in der stadt liegt bei
über 50 prozent aktuell geht man davon
aus dass die stadt über 400.000
einwohner hat wobei schwierig ist die
genaue einwohnerzahl in den
elendsvierteln zu ermitteln die mordrate
in der hauptstadt ist extrem hoch dies
liegt nicht zuletzt an dem kriminellen
banden den sogenannten rest collmex die
games rekrutieren ihre mitglieder
naturgemäß überwiegend in den
verhandlungs vierteln der stadt ihre
aktivitäten reichen von einem deutschen
überfällen teilweise sogar schwer
bewaffnet über diebstähle bis hin zum
organisierten internationalen
drogenhandel sehr häufig kommt es auch
zu sexueller gewalt gegenüber frauen in
einigen dieser längst gilt das
vergewaltigen einer frau als
aufnahmerituale in die bande besuchern
wird daher geraten ihre unterkunft
machst und untergang nicht mehr zu
verlassen und wenn möglich auch tagsüber
nicht auf die straße zu gehen aus diesem
grund wurde port moresby nicht nur von
uns zur gefährlichsten stadt in asien
ozeanien gewählt für frauen halten
einige sie sogar für die gefährlichste
stadt der welt eine stadt voll
vergewaltiger in erschreckender weise
haben laut einer un-studie 34 prozent
von 10.000 befragten wenn dann zwischen
850 jahren aus bangladesch kambodscha
china wie tunesien sri lanka und partner
genährt schon einmal eine frau innerhalb
oder außerhalb einer partnerschaft
vergewaltigt schlüsselt man diese
umfrage allerdings nach ländern auch
ergibt sich ein noch weit entsetzliches
bild nicht weniger als 41 prozent der
befragten männer in papua neuguinea
haben angegeben preis mindestens eine
frau außerhalb einer partnerschaft feld
und wald dich zu haben und so grauenvoll
es klingt das ist leider noch nicht
alles ein sehr großer teil der
bevölkerung papua neuguineas dem
aberglauben erlegen viele glauben an
die und hexen wird eine frau der hexerei
verdächtigt ist es nicht unüblich die zu
verfolgen zu foltern und zu verstümmeln
manche wurden sogar schon bei lebendigem
leibe verbrannt
ihr seht also es gibt da wohl wenig
zweifeln port moresby ist insbesondere
foul einer der schlimmsten orte der welt
eine wahrhaftige hölle auf erden
[Musik]
erinnerungen an afrika
platz drei in afrika geht an lagos mit
mehr als 14 millionen einwohner ist
lagos die zweitgrößte stadt afrikas und
die größte stadt nigerias die ist
außerdem das wirtschaftliche zentrum de
geas das sicherheitsproblem in lagos ist
derart bedrückend dass sogar viele
kinder aus angst vor entführungen die
schule schwänzen die örtliche polizei
ist mit der situation völlig überfordert
es gibt einfach zu wenig polizisten und
die die es gibt sind nur unzureichend
ausgebildet und werden schlecht bezahlt
das öffnet natürlich tür und tor für
kriminelle und gewalttätige banden vor
ort werden sie area boys genannt sie
setzten sich in der regel aus jungen
männern zusammen die häuser ausrauben
und auto stehlen gefährlich können aber
auch die oper das sein
[Musik]
okadas sind die lokal üblichen motorrad
taxis eigentlich bieten diese eine
einfache und schnelle lösung den
ständigen verkehrsstaus zu entkommen
würden sie sich doch mal an die
grundlegende verkehrsregeln halten wie
zum beispiel auf der richtigen
straßenseite zu fahren
[Musik]
ein okada zu buchen ist also auf der
schnellste weg um ins krankenhaus zu
kommen mitarbeiter des örtlichen
gesundheitswesens schätzen dass circa 45
prozent aller unfälle im zusammenhang
mit ocala stehen aber es gibt noch
andere probleme so fliegen einige der
okada fahrer verbindungen zu den jeweils
herrschenden area boys zudem gibt es
auch einfach zu viele von ihnen
schätzungsweise mehr als eine million
aus diesen gründen erwägen die örtlichen
behörden die okadas zu verbieten in
sechs regierungsbezirken wurde ein
solches motorrad ausgesprochen ist
darüber nachgedacht in betrieb und kann
das generell zu untersagen
die behörden sind sich allerdings auch
im klaren darüber dass ein solches
verbot die armut in lagos noch weiter
verschärfen wird nigeria ist schließlich
weltweit das land mit dem größten anteil
junger menschen innerhalb seiner
bevölkerung viele von ihnen sind
arbeitslos oder leben sehr prekären
verhältnissen es ist fraglich welchen
weg diese vielen menschen wählen werden
wenn man ihnen mit dem okadas ihre
einkommensquelle wegnimmt so mancher von
ihnen dürfte es dann glück dann
vielleicht in europas und
der an nummer zwei geht an den start die
hauptstadt der demokratischen republik
kongo ist die größte stadt afrikas und
sie war es so schön dass sie kinder bell
genannt wurde jedoch hatte sich so sehr
verändert das ihre einwohner sie 0
klingt labelle nennen was so viel
bedeutet wie in der mülleimer und als
auch der angesammelte müll und die
stecken die kanalisation nicht
unangenehm genug wäre wird die komplette
stadt auch noch von gewalttätigen banden
tyrannisiert wie den couloirs einer
gruppe junger männer die mit macheten
bewaffnete rauben und tritten in den
letzten jahren kamen dann auch noch die
kinder anna saum bis hin zu wodurch die
situation sich noch einmal verschärft
[Musik]
ein grund ist dass die menschen in den
strassen von gaza von einer neuen
billigen droge mit sehr starker wirkung
ein gesucht worden ich meine damit bombe
eine substanz die aus ablagerungen in
tera lisa toren alte autos hergestellt
wird schlägt lag gar nicht wahr das
rohmaterial wird aus alten autos von
schrottplätzen gewonnen und dann zu der
droge weiterverarbeitet
[Musik]
nach der einnahme von bombay geraten die
nicht direkt in einen zustand euphorie
innerhalb dessen sie hemmungslos jede
art von verbrechen begehen mit
anhaltender wirkung verlangsamt die
gruppe jedoch die bewegung der jungen
männer so dass sich schließlich die
songs wirken seit 2020 haben die kommune
aktivitäten in kinshasa weiter
zugenommen was zu einem anstieg der
kriminalität geführt hat einschließlich
bewaffneter raubüberfälle und
gewalttätiger übergriffe und wieder
einmal ist die armut die ursache für
einen großteil dieser kriminalität
großer teil der schätzungsweise 15
millionen menschen in diesem jahr sein
leben hat weder eine feste arbeit noch
ein regelmäßiges einkommen irgendeiner
hat falls sie also lust darauf hat eine
dystopische zombie apokalypse in real
life mit eigenen augen mitzuerleben die
nasa ist da genau das richtige reiseziel
und auf platz eins steht kapstadt
tja wer hätte das gedacht noch schlimmer
als die zombie apokalypse ist das
einstige und touristen noch immer sehr
beliebte kapstadt mit der einführung der
demokratie im jahr 1994 erlebnis
südafrika einen allgemeinen rückgang der
gewalt allerdings hat sich diese
positive entwicklung der letzten zehn
jahren nicht mehr fortgesetzt die
gewaltkriminalität ist innerhalb dieses
zeitraumes aufgrund einer gefährlichen
mischung aus armut leichten zugang zu
waffen und einer sagen der stark
verbesserungswürdigen polizeiarbeit
rasant angestiegen die mordrate des
inhalt des letzten jahrzehnts um
erschreckende 60 prozent in die höhe
geschossen besonders gefährlich ist es
mit fleiß den von gangs beherrschten
randbezirken kapstadt
[Musik]
diese ghettos waren der und der zeit der
apartheid für die schwarze bevölkerung
bestimmt und werden nun von gangs
regiert mit namen wie wm eric ist die
number stellen oder die larven boys es
gibt ca 130 dieser games und es wird
geschätzt dass in circa 130.000 menschen
aus dem flöz angehören in diesen
vierteln kommt es häufig zu
revierkämpfen zwischen einzelnen banken
diese lösen dann regelrechte gewalt
wellen aus die kapstadt regelmäßig
terrorisieren aber woher kommen
eigentlich all die waffen dienen
schlossen umlauf sind nun passt mal auf
dann mit sowas rechnet man bei uns
eigentlich eher nicht ex polizist erhält
18 jahre wegen diebstahls und
weiterverkauf von waffen an gangsta puck
ab insgesamt brachten ja mit mehr als
1000 oder 1500 mordversuche alleine
diesen waffen in verbindung und das
schlimmste daran ist dass es bei
illegalen waffenhandel nicht aufhört die
sicherheitsorgane selbst in weitere
kriminelle aktivitäten verstrickt
korrupte polizisten sollen sogar die
gerichtsakten von verhafteten band mit
ihnen manipuliert haben die verurteilung
skater für morde in den preis liegt bei
gerade mal zwei prozent angesichts
dieser aufklärungsquote ist es nicht
verwunderlich dass die straßenbahnen
ungestört ihre gebiete beherrschen
welche mittlerweile so viel sagenden
namen wie roboter taliban area oder
jungle tragen ja man kann kapstadt
besuchen und eine tolle zeit haben aber
ab sei es der luxushotels in der teuren
viertel die ist eine parallele realität
die kapstadt fest im griff hält
[Musik]
der content der unbegrenzten der fahren
auf dem dritten platz ist süd und
nordamerika liegt san pedro sula
lateinamerika ist nach wie vor die
gewalttätigste regierung der welt drogen
handeln banken konflikte korruption und
ist sozial schwächer tragen überall in
der region zu einem hohen maß an gewalt
bei jahrelang druck san pedro sula den
unrühmlichen titel die stadt mit den
meisten morden auf der welt zu sein
während es in städten wie new york so
circa sechs morden auf 100.000 einwohner
im jahr kommt sind es dieser stadt etwa
170 san pedro sula ist das wichtigste
wirtschaftliche zentrum in hundes und
das mag nicht zuletzt an seiner für den
drogenhandel strategisch wichtigen lage
legen zeitweise fließen durch die stadt
bis zu 80 prozent des in die vereinigten
staaten geschmuggelten kokains die stadt
selbst und das sie umgebende gebiet wird
von den maras kontrolliert diese sind
international aktive kriminelle
organisation und welches ausmaß diese
kontrolle angenommen hat könnt ihr hier
ist
die mara salvatrucha installierte
kameras in form von san pedro sula um
die bevölkerung und die polizei zu
kontrollieren die perspektivlosigkeit
bringt mir das sehr junge menschen dazu
sich den maras anzuschließen einige sind
erst zwölf wenn sie in die band kommen
ein großes problem bei der bekämpfung
der maras ist die bestechung darüber wie
die korruption aus honduras die hölle
auf erden gemacht hat haben wir sogar
ein eigenes video gedreht das ich euch
verlinkt werden der staat versucht zwar
bereits seit jahren seine
sicherheitskräfte irgendwie von
korruption zu befreien und dies zeigt
manchmal sogar einwirkungen denn es ist
gelungen die gewalt ein wenig
einzudämmen dennoch ist das ganze land
dermaßen aus den fugen geraten dass
erpressungen und entführungen immer noch
eine tagesordnung sind und von einer
entspannung der lage keine rede sein
kann
das zwei geht an saint louis
ja ich spreche von saint-louis in den
usa überrascht nun diese stadt an dieser
position unser ranking aufnehmen zu
müssen hat uns auch erstaunt so sehr
dass er sogar dazu entschlossen haben
darüber ein separates video zu drehen
ganz genau die unglaublichen umständen
ist endlos bieten unglaublich viel
weitgehend unbekannten stoff zum gruseln
und auch lernen vergesst also bitte
nicht das abo und vor allem das
glöckchen damit unser kommt das video
über diese ob es statt des horrors nicht
entgeht ich danke euch sind los ist eine
stadt mit circa 300.000 einwohnern im
bundesstaat missouri und mit ihrer
überwiegend afro amerikanischen
bevölkerung dass sie die höchste
gewaltrate in den usa regelmäßig kommt
es vor allem in den nördlichen vororten
zu schießereien es handelt sich um einen
ähnlichen fall bietet schuld aber dass
wir auch schon ein video gemacht haben
nur noch schlimmer die florierende stadt
an den letzten jahrzehnten aufgrund
diverser krieg ist eine große zahl von
einwohnern verloren einst im 19
jahrhundert war sind es nämlich die
viertgrößte stadt der usa vor ihr lagen
nur new york das damals noch unabhängige
buckland und latakia an seine damalige
einwohnerzahl kommt sind los heute nicht
mehr heran und die tendenz ist eher
abnehmen dementsprechend entwickelt sich
das stadtzentrum
rückläufig die behörden mussten aus der
not bereits eine tugend machen und auf
den grundstücken von verlassenen
gebäuden teigs einrichten sodass ich
sind los heute rühmen kann mehr als 1000
tags zu unterhalten überraschender weise
sind games in saint-louis kein besonders
herausragendes problem drogenhandel und
waffengewalt sind ist aber dennoch im
jahr 2020 stellte die stadt an bis es
liegt die ihren makabren rekord auf 262
morden und einem einzigen jahr ja fast
scheint es so als wäre die kriminellen
bewohner dieser stadt revolutionär schon
derart zurück gefallen dass sie sich
noch nicht einmal in gruppen
organisieren können der degeneration
fällt jedoch auch die verwaltung der
stadt heim mangelnde einnahmen führen
dazu dass ihre ausgaben stark
einschränken muss aus diesem grund
mangelt es überall an polizei so dass es
endlos erschreckenderweise nur ein
drittel der tötungsdelikte aufgeklärt
werden kann zwei drittel der männer
gehen ungeschoren davon und das in einem
erst welt land aber wie gesagt über all
dies erzählen wir euch bald in einem
eigenen video
auf platz eins steht caracas die wenn es
solar mission hauptstadt erlebt eine
noch nie dagewesene welle der gewalt
unter der ire 5 millionen einwohner
zunehmend leiden müssen darüber hinaus
müssen sie eine ständige
verschlechterung öffentlicher leistungen
miterleben deren ursache in der
misswirtschaft des staates bis der
regimes liegt weniger als ein fünftel
wenn es so lana fühlen sich sicher wenn
sie nachts auf die straße gehen deswegen
in vielen nach 18 uhr gar nicht mehr aus
dem haus aber auch dort haben sie
keinerlei garantie in sicherheit zu sein
das ausmaß an gewalt sind die polizei
zur regelmäßigen razzien bei denen sie
oft waffen findet die bewohner sehen
sich genötigt mit waffen für ihre eigene
sicherheit zu sorgen der polizei
vertraut man in venezuela nämlich schon
lange nicht mehr während man straftaten
zb in brasilien durchaus noch der
polizei meldet tut dies in wenn israel
ein niemand mehr jeder weiß wie stark
die sicherheitsbehörden durch kriminelle
banden mit ihrer platte a propos methode
beeinflusst werden geld- oder vielleicht
dennoch kommt es zu teilweise sehr
heftigen gewalttätigen konflikten
zwischen der polizei und einzeln
kriminellen banken geht das öffentliche
leben komplett lahmlegen in einigen
bezirken caracas wie zb der kino-version
ko system liefern sich sicherheitskräfte
und ging es besonders packte und
langwierige gefechte denn nachdem der
polizei auch noch vorgeworfen wurde
verdächtige einfach zu exekutieren kam
es zu verhandlungen mit den kriminellen
banden der deals lehmann gelangte war
aber durchaus fragen ich gebe ihnen
wurden in der kutter 905 von den anderen
bezirken eine sogenannte friedens zone
eingerichtet diese dürften von
polizeikräften gar nicht mehr betreten
werden und werden somit faktisch von den
gangs kontrolliert und dass dies nicht
zu einer abnahme der allgemeinen gewalt
führte ist wohl offensichtlich bei
visual politik wissen wir nur zu gut wie
es um die diktatur von nicolás maduro
bestellt ist allerdings müssen dass auch
einige macht uci in caracas stellen
wenn es so lange sicherheitskräfte töten
elky den mutmaßlichen anführer einer
bande die caracas terrorisierte die
durch die misswirtschaft erzeugte
hyperinflation hat die venezolanische
gesellschaft total verarmen lassen dabei
entstand eine tiefe kluft zwischen denen
die zugang tour dollars haben und dem
rest der bevölkerung diese ausweglose
situation hat vielen bewohnern und
caracas keine andere möglichkeit mehr
gelassen als ich in die kriminalität zu
flüchten nun könnt ihr euch sicher
vorstellen wie begehrt dollars in
caracas sein müssen seit in dieser stadt
also besonders vorsichtig und lasst bloß
niemanden eure brieftasche sehen und
wenn dann bitte nur eine mit dem
wertlosen polizei aber ich weiß dass
viele von euch jetzt denken war das
jetzt alles wollt ihr mexiko nicht
einmal erwähnt nun aufgepasst
ein land in der sackgasse
unser allergrößtes mitgefühl gilt an
dieser stelle allen zuschauern die uns
aus mexiko zu sehen oder aus diesem land
kommen damit wir uns nicht falsch
verstehen es handelt sich um ein
großartiges land denn noch hat mexiko
ein ganz eigenes kapitel verdient wenn
es um gefährliche städte geht es ist
sozusagen ein eigener kontinent becker
wald mit nichts anderem zu vergleichen
und deswegen läuft es auch bei uns
völlig außerhalb der konkurrenz
jahr für jahr stehen die städte des
landes an der spitze der welt drin ist
das für die zahl der mordopfer das land
hat das pech direkt zwischen den kuka
feldern südamerikas und den vereinigten
staaten dem größten drogenmarkt der welt
zu liegen wie also sieht die unrühmliche
rangliste innerhalb mexikos aus nun auf
platz drei in mexiko liegt ciudad juarez
jahre lang war die grenzstadt ciudad
juarez das blutigste schlachtfeld im
krieg der mexikanischen regierung gegen
die drogen in der 1,5 millionen
metropole wurden mehr als 300 morde pro
monat verpressung entführung und
autodiebstahl waren an der tagesordnung
dies würde dazu dass die stadt als die
gefährlichste stadt der welt bekannt
wurde in ihrem kampf um territorien
haben sich die einst großen kartelle wie
zum beispiel das schier allmächtiger
horas kartell gegenseitig geschwächt und
letztendlich zersplittert dazu hat auch
die sogenannte kind bin strategy der usa
beigetragen die darin besteht vor allem
die führungsperson der kartelle zu töten
anders als beabsichtigt lösten sich die
kartelle dadurch aber nicht auf sonst
fielen in viele kleine kartelle dadurch
ist die zahl der gewalttaten natürlich
nicht zurückgegangen im gegenteil denn
die großen kartelle hielten sich trotz
ihrer massiven brutalität noch an
gewisse regeln von oben und mit dem
zusammenbruch dieser razzien ist auch
diese ordnung verschwunden so den druck
in den letzten jahren der macht in den
usa nicht nur vor kokain sondern auch
mit amphetamin auch als crystal bekannt
nun kämpfen viele kleiner kartelle um
ihren anteil an diesen großen geschäft
dadurch ist die gewalt in dieser stadt
direkt an der grenze zu texas auf der
anderen seite gleich el paso liegt noch
weiter eskaliert
run nummer zwei geht an acapulco
bitte berücksichtigt dass die position
dieser rangliste nicht nur von der zahl
der mörder abhängt wir haben auch
weitere faktoren in unser ganz
persönliches ranking mit einfließen
lassen was acapulco angeht so kamen 1990
er jahren wie strände dieser stadt in
mode und erlangten aufgrund ihrer
schönheit und ihre präsenz in den medien
weltweite berühmtheit doch im jahr 2007
begannen die probleme ernst zu werden
nachdem sich das damals dominante
kartell aufgespalten hatte bracht chaos
und gewalt aus führungspositionen
einzelner drogen partnern waren
plötzlich war typ geworden und nach den
entsprechenden kämpfen wurde diese
schnell von kleineren lokalen gruppen
besetzt hier durch einen brand zwischen
diesen einen noch brutaler kampf um
territorien es bedeutet das aus für das
idyllische urlaubsziel acapulco nun ja
der bürgermeister hatte für all diese
probleme allerdings schnell eine
einfachere lösung gefunden
schreibt nicht über gewalt den tourismus
zuliebe sagt der bürgermeister von
acapulco zu reportern ganz klar herr
bürgermeister verbrechen wie in führung
und erpressungen oder morden verhindert
man am besten indem man nicht darüber
spricht dass währenddessen soldaten an
den stränden patroullieren müssen wird
die touristen sicher beruhigen das
eigentliche problem aber bleibt ungelöst
und die kriminellen banden können sich
weiter straffreiheit durch die stadt
bewegen und ihre verbrechen begehen in
acapulco gibt ist kein dominierendes
kartell mehr sondern nur noch viele
kleine meist verfeindeten organisationen
die sich den handel mit heroin widmen
dieses wird aus wohn hergestellt der im
ganzen bundesstaat guerrero reichlich
angebaut wird von dort aus wird es in
die vereinigten staaten verkauft und
inzwischen ist er ja wo es viele drogen
gibt gibt es auch viele probleme
und auf platz 1d horner
die horner ist vielleicht die
gefährlichste stadt der welt der kampf
gegen den drogenhandel ist auch in
dieser grenzstadt embacher california
nach hinten losgegangen die
gefangennahme der einst mächtigen
drogenbosse haben dazu geführt dass die
kartelle wie auch in ciudad juarez
zersplittert sind und sich nun
gegenseitig bekämpfen die hana wurde
dadurch zu einem regelrechten
schlachtfeld die mordrate hat sich in
den letzten fünf jahren fast
verdreifacht und liegt 20 mal höher als
der weltweite durchschnitt dort werden
so viele menschen getötet dass selbst
die gutachter rest nicht mehr mithalten
kann und vielleicht kennt ihr eines der
letzten opfer im kampf des staates gegen
das organisierte verbrechen
die journalistin nodes maldonado
berichtete vor ihrer ermordung kritisch
über führende politiker und ihre
verstrickung in korrupte machenschaften
im zusammenhang mit drogen und
menschenhandel diesbezüglich befand er
sich sogar in einem rechtsstreit mit dem
ex-gouverneur carbonia einen vertreter
der regierungspartei selbst die
journalistin war sich der gefahr bewusst
sein der sich befand und bat kurz vor
ihrem putin präsidenten des landes
andrés manuel lópez obrador kurs am loh
und schutz zu erleben leider vergeblich
damit ist nur dass maldonado eine von
drei journalisten welche innerhalb von
nur wenigen wochen in mexiko ermordet
worden
nach all diesen grausamkeiten hoffe ich
dass er noch die kraft bietet uns einen
kommentar zu hinterlassen
wir würden uns sehr darüber freuen denkt
ihr zum beispiel dass irgendeine stadt
in diesem ranking zählt auf welchem wege
ist eurer meinung nach europa wenn es
darum geht in diesem punkt anschluss an
den rest der welt zu finden welche
folgen haben die zustände an den
erwähnten orten auch für uns zum
beispiel bezüglich des themas migration
auf jeden fall sind auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt falls ihr dieses
video gut fand und hab ich mich auch
etwas gelernt habt vergesst nicht erst
zu leiten ist mit euren freunden zu
teilen und natürlich auch nicht das abo
mit glöckchen keines unserer - messungen
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
über eine spende von euch mit de dieses
projekt unterstützen könnte den link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video machs gut und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]